cardinals go with quan young kim
today and we'd like to see him get deep
into this game that's something that's
really been happening more and more
the last few days for the cardinal
starters they'll play straight up here
it seems with a eugenio suarez standing
in runner at first
swang and a mess and kim
has his first strikeout of the night so
goldschmidt will play behind the runner
off with the pitch the 3-2
swung on and missed back-to-back case
sonny gray gets loose no score
bottom one at busch stadium continues to
try to kick a little crevice for himself
full count
payoff pitch strike three call
he's gotten two of those now and that
breaking ball that looks a little off
the plate away
the drop off from goldschmidt arenado
has been dramatic
pin point from sonny gray
he looks outstanding in the first a
couple of k's and perfect
scoreless game for a while there it
seemed like senzelle was going to be
you know he got that one good
loops that breaking ball to williams
he's going to take a turn
and a chance to second slides in ahead
of the throw then squirts free
and there's a hustle double for nick
sims hill
here's yada year molina the 01.
and molina hits it down the left field
line it's hooking in
it is gone how about yachty
what a start his fifth home run
keep on doing it yachty one nothing
cardinals
these are the moments that you're glad
that they're fans in the ballpark
i mean the cardboard cutouts just really
couldn't do it justice
the reaction afterwards that's what the
players have been saying they love
having people at the park
for big moments like that for curtin
calls
and yadier molina of course the guy that
everybody loves to cheer
for at busch stadium
swing of the miss breaking ball snapped
off three k's for gray
2-2
and the strikeout of sunny grave
here's the 1-2 pitch with two outs
swinging and a miss
castiano strikes out two strikeouts in
the inning four in the game
for kwan young kim
one and two the count gray's pitch to
kim
that is chopped toward third base slowly
hit gray off the mound throws safe at
first
coming off the bag botto plays it on a
hop to keep the ball from going down the
right field line
bong young cam with his first major
league hit
throw that baseball out get it get it
and the lead off man is on
what you want to see runners on for paul
goldsmith nolan arenado
outfield very deep shading of a bit to
right field
the 1-1 goldschmidt rips it down the
left-field line
fair into the corner one run is in
here comes another goldsmith drives in
two
three nothing saint louis
here's nolan oronato
base head into right goldsmith
being waved in throw by castillanos cut
off
and nolan oronato drives in paul
goldschmidt
four nothing cardinals
now yadier molina the pitch by sonny
gray a swing and a drive
it's in the gap right center field
that's down going to the wall
here comes aronado he's going to score
on the double by yadi air molina
five-nothing cardinals and the two rbi
night for molina
[Applause]
the 3-2 pitch swung on and missed so
after a 3-0 count kim comes back
and strikes out suarez with a slow ball
doing the change up hit and goes
swinging a miss strikeout number six
three in a row
kim from the stretch the pitch a swing
popped him up
short left center field out goes to
young the shortstop he calls he's under
it he has it
two hits after two outs and two left on
now the base is loaded for arnotto
three consecutive walks a one
that's in the air blandino
loses his footing but catches the ball
and that'll leave him loaded
and a swing and a miss strikeout number
seven that's a new career high for kim
swing and a miss and a strikeout for kim
and that's eight tonight through five
here's a 3-2 pitch to molina
and a swing and a miss yeah something's
not quite right there
andrew kisner will take over behind the
plate so molina
out of the game we noticed the
uncomfortable at-bat that he had
and that was the pitch there and he did
roll his foot over watch the front foot
and you're going to do that a little bit
anyway but it was a little bit too much
and i think
had too much weight perhaps on that
front foot
at in that awkward position and yadi was
limping around the rest of that at bat
castiano's booze have lightened as the
game's gone on
castellanos drills this one pretty deep
center field
his 1000th career hit his team leading
seventh home run and listen to him boo
[Applause]
the ball got thrown back onto the field
that's why you heard those late cheers
five and two-thirds strong baseball
tonight from the lefty
kk yeah terrific job exactly what the
cardinals needed then
we talked about it being good down in
the zone a lot of pitches down
and a lot of swings and misses down not
just with the fastball but also
with the breaking ball down in the zone
and
he really controlled counts controlled
the game and
had a lot of animation along the way and
picked up his first bit one on one out
jonathan india batch with blandino at
second
to right field and it falls in
miscommunication blandino given the wave
he rips around third
india steaming the third base relay to
third the helmet flies
and india slides in safely and the reds
get a run they're within three
the tying run is going to be on deck how
does that ball
fall in tying run aboard only one out
winker has two hits tonight a couple of
singles
what could winker do with it
downstairs and he walks in a run and
that
forces the tying run into scoring
position and the go ahead run as a board
it's five to three
castillanos homer back in the sixth that
was career hit number one
thousand down two in the ninth one out
[Music]
it gets by a break for the plate
and another run barnhart crosses it's a
one-run
game three runs in in the ninth
hey eugenio suarez 3-2 pitch
he got him cold third strike
reyes and the cardinals hold on
five for the final he froze him at the
end